I think you've just got a glimpse of the future
of education.
The runaway success of Khan Academy, which
launched in 2008,
showed the potential for online learning to
revolutionize K-12 education.
It meant that a great classroom lecture could
be experienced by anyone anywhere.
And learning software from companies like
dreambox could act as a personal tutor.
We've developed the intelligent, adaptive
learning technology
that celebrates student learning.
Twelve years later, classrooms mostly look
like they always have
and many teachers are skeptical that technology
can fundamentally remake classroom instruction.
This whole idea of turning over education
to technology takes away the human element.
Computers have been used in classrooms since
the 1980s.
By 2000 there was one PC for every five students
in American classrooms.
In 2008, the same year that Khan Academy launched,
the legendary business professor Clayton Christensen,
who passed away last week at the age of 67,
co-authored a book applying his theory of
disruptive innovation to the classroom.
When used disruptively, software could solve
the problem of students learning at different speeds.
While some are bored, others are struggling
to keep up.
Christensen and his co-authors wanted to flip
the structure of the classroom
and make is student centric.
They would watch online courses given by the
world's best instructors.
Educational apps would gamify learning, help
track progress
and personalize the content.
Teachers could then use classroom time to
help students tackle bigger, more conceptual problems.
Christensen and his co-authors predicted that
by 2018
about 50% of high school classes would be
delivered online.
And they dismissed the objection that government
bureaucracies and teachers unions
would stand in the way of rapid change.
Their prediction didn't come true.
I would say the biggest lesson that I've had
is not that I'm disappointed
but just that it takes a long time to do this.
Michael Horn, who was one of Christensen's
co-authors,
is a Harvard MBA who specializes in education
technology.
You're trying to overthrow literally a century
of policy and practice
around our current school system
and all of a sudden we come along and say
'wait a second, we're not doing it the right
way.'
Schools have continued to integrate computers
into classrooms
but Horn says they haven't brought fundamental
change.
We think that every student, because they're
in fifth grade for example,
should be doing the exact same thing at the
exact same time
and we should test on those exact same things.
We literally fund schools based on the number
of minutes that students sit in seats
not on how much they learn.
Disrupting Class included a plea to philanthropists
to help fund this disruption.
Foundations answered that call but with limited
impact.
Take Summit Learning which is backed by Mark
Zuckerberg and Bill Gates.
Its goal was to be in fifty percent of public
schools by 2025.
Over one hundred million dollars later, it's
used in just four tenths of one percent.
Although according to the education news site
Chalkbeat
Summit declined the opportunity to be studied
by a team of Harvard researchers
it can point to anecdotal successes.
Such as the experience of one public middle
school in Washington D.C.
So we got wind of this program and said like
'hey let's try it.'
Like let's pilot it.
Summit Learning flew teachers to California
for training
and covered the entire cost of llthe program.
We saw just student engagement increase
and actually like behavioral referrals decrease
because students were engaged 100%.
Denise Edwards tied teachers' performance
evaluations to the new online curriculum.
As a teacher you want that control over your
classroom
like this is your space, this is your baby
and like letting go brings about fear.
But Emily Raskin, a math teacher at another
D.C. high school
says that the flipped classroom model ignores
the realities of student behavior.
I think that we look at the next big thing
that looks great to adults
and assume that it's going to be the same
thing for kids.
So if you assign them to watch a video, for
example at home one night,
that is maybe ten minutes long,
by 30 seconds in, if they're not really interested,
they just kind of zone out
and they come to school the next day really
believing that they have watched the video.
In some schools where Summit was implemented
parents fought to overturn it.
Parents and students often just don't know
what they don't know about school.
They don't know what it could be, what opportunities
they might be missing.
The subjects that we cover in the electronic
apps are science, history, geography,
we do music, Spanish, math, art.
According to Clayton Christensen's theory
of disruptive innovation
change happens first in the segments of the
market so insignificant
that nobody is really paying attention to
them
but eventually they grow to overtake the industry.
Disrupting Class gives home schoolers as an
example.
Melissa Kigin is a mother of five in rural
Maryland.
And I'm not a teacher, I'm not trained to
be a teacher,
I don't think you need to have that in order
to home school if you have apps like these.
We're living in this moment I think where
we can reshape the models at the heart of education
and leverage these tools and technologies.
Are we on the eve of seeing the end of the
traditional classroom?
No reason why it really can't happen in every
classroom in America tomorrow.
Or perhaps Christensen and Horn are guilty
as the saying goes
of mistaking a clear view of the future for
a short distance.
The current classroom model may survive for
a long time to come
at least until software gets better at approximating
student-teacher interactions.
And when change does occur, chances are it
will look nothing like we had imagined.